well you know interestingly and I've
just gotten back into town and I was at
the FBI National Executive Institute and
just yesterday we studied Martin Luther
King his letter from the Birmingham jail
and her speech the night before his
assassination and in that letter from
the jail in Birmingham he woke in
response to letters from the clergy
predominantly the white clergy and he
called on them to take a stand and
ironically I think that's what you're
seeing this is the first event of is is
the faith community in Charleston as
well as the greater community all of
whom sent feel a sense of hurt anger
betrayal and but I think this is going
to result in folks coming together in
ways that have not been seen there is
something unique about this community
and we've been unfortunately in the news
a great deal lately and and yet we've
been able to handle that differently
than a lot of other communities and it's
because of the relationship that exists
within the greater community let me say
that there aren't problems but you have
those you have those relationships that
are a great foundation for healing and
and and
and morning in in in unison and and
that's that's what we're going through
right now